I got my main [ __ ] in the house
piece I'm on out of Philly my man the
flying you direct from Jerusalem my you
kidding or what what's happening brother
now much dude it's it's been an
interesting couple hours I mean last
night when he texted me I went to Paul's
like okay check see she's like I thought
I didn't text I'm gonna go shoot
something movie going down last night it
was going down last night you understand
me let me tell you sir my biggest fear
is needles yeah my biggest fear is
needles in the world I hate going for
them you know when I cop to them when
you call me and go Joe you have to come
in for a shot or something I go yeah and
I play it off in the night before I'm a
[ __ ] mess like the night before
before I go to bed of ICH me as I put
the sleep apnea mask on that I gotta go
for a shot so I'm always a little [ __ ]
up week so I'm gonna get blood test I
shot my knee even had punctured the
night before it bothers me for like
three minutes
acupuncture not anymore because I'm used
to it yesterday I had to go shoot my
knee so you need to drive to do it look
I have to drive to Marina del Rey which
you know and they put like this little
thing on your knee they scope it and he
could see the knee and the joint the
cartilage and he shoots it right into
your [ __ ] knee I'm looking at you two
guys from my heart and telling you I
didn't feel the needle oh wow dr.
Niccole is a genius I've been going back
to Nicole did my surgery you know he
took care of my toe when I broke it my
wrist when I heard is getting thrown at
[ __ ] jiu-jitsu he took care of this
knee and yesterday you know had a
payment for the medication even though
I'm level one insurance it's a it's a
new drug they shot my left knee and it's
not cortisone and what my left knee was
different because they have to give me
three different shots every week for
three different weeks so I had to drive
down to every Monday at 11 o'clock this
was six months ago and it controls the
arthritis and it creates like a seal
around your cartilage and it repairs the
cartilage it helps to repair the
cartilage to give you that cushion in
the knee so yesterday morning I had to
go that was all I had on my agenda
yesterday and you know made though I'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know the reason why I
get fired up like this Lee isn't because
I get fired up and I'm some [ __ ]
[ __ ] I have to talk myself into
things you have to
talk yourself into things and you have
to call yourself a [ __ ] [ __ ] a
[ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] whatever came
whatever it takes you know so you know
me I get to the furrow five minutes
traffic right away I'm trying
[ __ ] right you know right away
I'm turning that [ __ ] around
I went by off to 101 Lee whatever you
[ __ ] name is Steve Simone that the
[ __ ] cars at 10:15 we'll pass up over
them
oh yeah so do you understand me like the
support van exit was packed where a lot
of people mistake themselves and get
caught in that that's why when I go to
the 405 I stay in the left-hand Lane
because if you're not thinking of your
stone that's people like me you get
caught in that line and all sudden when
you get to it you're not waiting for
four or five you waiting for Sepulveda
but not yesterday yesterday this up over
line was all the way back to Laurel
Canyon well I'm the 405 line know until
about 11 o'clock you if you get in that
line for the 405 you're gonna be there
for 40 minutes
so forty minutes you have your [ __ ]
ass you have to cut it you feel like an
[ __ ] we have to cut in line that loop
to get them the 101 to the 405
yeah to go south south it's gonna be 30
40 minutes they won't let nobody on
nobody was letting the cut yesterday oh
so I passed it and I go I'm not gonna
doctor by the way the [ __ ] of me came
up I'm gonna go home I'm gonna smoke
some pot [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that I got off in Haskell next one yeah
high school you get off and you hit
mentor and you hit Ventura and Sepulveda
and guess what no lie no lie right and I
got on that and I even call the doctor
it was 10:20 and my point was 11 I even
called this i'ma be 15 minutes later
look at the traffic was bumper-to-bumper
and I thought they closed the HOV Lane I
realized I was in the HOV Lane that puts
holes on this Lane at the outside I got
that tender [ __ ] 11
oh my god I got in I walked in there
walked upstairs had my pot on I put on
[ __ ] bushes great as its he came in I
mean I was at in my car by 11:30 in my
car so there was no thought like usually
once I get to the doctor's office if
there's thought about this shot that
even scares the [ __ ] out of me get know
she said get pail you go right in the
girl I want to thank Miranda visa she
works for him
and it's funny because when I first
started going to Miranda off the dr.
Niccole like the first visit everybody
was nice to me and the second visit the
girl came in she goes you know my
uncle's [ __ ] love you and they're
like [ __ ] thugs like they [ __ ]
love you dog she takes care of me
because and she calls me uncle Joey
because I like this so like thanks
Friday they'll be at the ice house oh
that's awesome
they'll come up when she comes up with
her family the cousins are all yoked up
in fact when I was there yesterday like
they want to know when you're gonna do
it jujitsu tournament you know is that
true that you fighting boy your three
stay and metamoris and [ __ ] like they
always bust my head's awesome so I don't
even have to call the office I just hit
her up on Facebook and go Moran that
want to come in from Miami and she'll
set it all up oh that's my so last night
I got a send like a box of yum yum
donuts or something down there what's up
[ __ ] Lika nothing I can only feel this
Gumi coming in so they [ __ ] three of
Lisa ATS workout I'm very proud of him
I'm trying he's trying he knows he knows
and then with the Florida thing you told
me was gonna have it happen so yeah are
the first day I went early in the day
and I liked it but it was [ __ ] I
slept the rest of the day when I got
home the body went the shot yeah new 15
links on here below so watch you and
Rogan and I couldn't do that I watched a
little bit but I passed out and I slept
probably from then I woke up like a
couple hours but mostly all day and then
yesterday Paul came over some wanted to
go later in the afternoon and I was
words gonna be packed it wasn't they
have a lot of machines over there but I
did I could do 15 on the elliptical
instead of 10 I was dying and then I
went to the bike and a lot of people say
they get motivated by like to really and
really fit people and that doesn't do
anything for me cuz I know I'm never
gonna be able to do that so I look for
the fat people and I come like yeah
there's a lot of fat people here and I
just happened to be next to a chubby
black guy and I like Paulo finished a
little bit before me and she said and I
said I just wanted to get to 15 minutes
on the bike
cuz I was at like 6 and as soon I got
off at 15 on the dot and as soon as I
got off the black guy like tap me on the
shoulder he's like you got to 15 right
yeah he's like good for you for coming
out man it takes a lot of mental stuff
anything I've been coming for two months
I went from 315 to 298 wow that's that's
all you did everything cuz I was dying
but like just that little bit of night
because I would never do it but that
little bit of niceness the heat and I
like I'm gonna look for him again now
because it's amazing someone you were a
kid and you try to do something for
yourself people goof on you break your
balls like it if I can't imagine like in
Philly like you got up in the morning
somebody's doing a rock people up [ __ ]
you know it's like a fortune that's
changed that's changed yeah when you go
to a gym now and you cease like this
times I'm at the wine I see somewhere
it's five years older than me 50 pounds
heavier than me I'm walking and when
they get off I give them a [ __ ] good
fee the bass says it may feel good you
know why you remember Christy Miller
yeah it's telling these guys in the
podcast that Christy Miller used to work
at Gold's Gym on Gower
yeah okay the [ __ ] capital of gayness
yeah I think so I'm still there this is
15 years ago this girl cared about me
and one day she pulled me aside she
didn't want to embarrass me she was Joey
I think the world of you before I quit
Gold's I signed you up for the executive
platinum deal all you got to do is show
up Lee it took me three months I would
drive there and look at the building and
[ __ ] no parking yeah
no parking cuz there's never any parking
and one day I said this girl went out
our way to get me a membership and I
went in there I wanna start us all and I
didn't even do the machines of the
epileptic 'old and I was so [ __ ] far
behind I went right for the bench
breasts and the [ __ ] curls and then
squats and I'm killing myself and I had
to be at that time maybe 360 was the
beginning of the end and this you know
every night man and whatever so what
they were gay so what did they come up
to and go listen man we're here for you
Wow if some would be one guy came up to
me because I've been watching you
you know work on your phone but he
doesn't want you to take it easy because
I come here every night I see that you
come people are very supportive Jim it's
not [ __ ] the the country is suffering
from an epidemic yeah that we didn't
know it was gonna come to this what is
kind of [ __ ] up that we have to pay to
go somewhere to work out if we told
someone when like who were farmers hey
we have to pay money to go get exercise
what are you talking about just go out
in the field and do work
I got thought about that I was paying
the thing I'm like it's kind of [ __ ]
up that we have to pay the programmed
for that your program to exercise your
body needs it but as technology started
to make life easier
that's why you need to get listen all
these parts now especially in Hollywood
North Hollywood in the valley whether
you go to this park there's a park off
Moore Park all kinds a kids park they
have a basketball court debut little
deep deep deep in the baseball courts on
the other side there's a walkway there's
a thing that you could walk because I
take Marcie up there that's right unless
she doesn't like plans that Park she
likes run around and play at that field
but in the corner there's a workout area
they have a pull-up bar and in a squat
machine it's all bodyweight yeah if you
have North Hollywood Park theirs is
phenomenal phenomenal they have the
treadmill without the machine that
you're doing it and you're gonna be
moving because there's no controller and
you get on that [ __ ] and your
legs start [ __ ] shaking you know what
to do North Hollywood Park is the
greatest secret if you want to lose
weight like now I'm lazy but when I
first moved here my wife doesn't get up
to eight or seven or my wife leaves
early in the morning I would drop her
off in Park at North Hollywood Park and
get super stoned in the [ __ ] car
super jacked up and I'd walk four times
around me you walk around North
Hollywood Park four times see what
happens to you see what happens and
that's perfect but I don't know about
for you for me I needed to pay the go to
the gym because I'm never gonna go right
you won't go yet the Jewish yeah you pay
now you got to get what's coming to you
you know and then when they start
hitting you for the 60s and the 70s you
know I told not to go to like LA Fitness
there's a lot of gyms run it just rip
you off then you have you sign a
contract dog it's 2014
we ensign no [ __ ] contract
like I know that it raises your
commitment level to some degree but at
the other degree the genders don't give
a [ __ ] about your commitment right they
give a [ __ ] about your money
you know if somebody really cares about
you they care about your health you
following me
after why are you going in fill out
paperwork that you don't have a job and
they'll give you a scholarship if you
could show you're a [ __ ] worthless
sack of [ __ ] you're just a worthless
sack of [ __ ] don't want to get a job it
looks like you're walking around the
[ __ ] North Hollywood yeah but if not
it looks like your MP I'm telling you
man people are supportive in these gyms
they're not there to [ __ ] put you
down straight out there giggling at you
like they were in high school and when
you see somebody fat and you make eye
contact with them that means the world
for them yeah
that means the world to them yeah I
really want to get this thing going
where I like to get like a club or
jiu-jitsu guys they're over 40 to get
together once a week to somewhere and I
in North Hollywood and maybe rest a lot
in [ __ ] North Hollywood Park cuz
that'd be great
guys over 40 the guys are my aides I
could really no ego don't we go that I
could really judge my what I'm doing
because part of the guy's a problem when
you go to jujitsu I on your 50 you're
rolling around with guys at 25 you know
and it sucks ass they got [ __ ] that you
don't got I mean the 25 year gap you
know really [ __ ] makes it different
so but no Lee I'm proud of you that he
made the choice you are like I cut coke
out that's gone just water you 25 years
old you know what it's all I wish I was
25 years old now yeah to tell you how
easy it it could be went because you
don't want to do this when you're 40 no
when you're 40 there's gonna come a time
you're gonna gain 30 pounds and you're
gonna go you know what I really did this
yeah I did this so this is coming right
off yeah but right now you're 25 right
now your metabolism you could [ __ ]
eat a cake and it's gone within ten
minutes it should be well not mine but
yeah it should be because you haven't
kicked that [ __ ] engine and you
got an engine yeah in the 70s there was
Pennzoil and Penhall's model was he
could pay me now yeah
oh you could pay me later that stuck
with me for my life those people that
drive around on change the oil in their
engine blows up and they go what the
[ __ ] happened and that was their motto
either you could pay me a dollar
ninety-nine now or you can pay me 800
later you're gonna pay me so you got to
get into exercising yeah you know and I
did it as a child and when I got into
comi I sold my soul so deeply into
economy that I go who needs their
fitness you always need your fitness in
my body so we need to breathe you always
need that power for yourself that power
for yourself is so spectacular yeah my
wife left the other day she came back
and I could see it she was a different
person and I go you got to do this three
days a week that [ __ ] lunatic came
home the other day when I did she was
gonna go back to work full-time I had to
shut her down like are you [ __ ] crazy
you do part-time with this human
kettlebell because that's what my
daughter is she's a human [ __ ]
kettlebell dog okay you know you carry
her around all [ __ ] day
you don't need yoga that's nice you
don't need weights you don't need
[ __ ] stretching so the and I said
well there's a 630 yoga class Tuesday
night I go go down there for now you
talked to some people listen man when I
talk to you when was the last time I
mean you got emotional we don't we talk
about podcasting or stupid [ __ ] jokes
or Steve Simone in his podcast or Rick
Ramos or a movie or hummus you know it's
really nice to 12 to people that just
want to talk sometimes I think I go to
jujitsu because I'm gonna be a world
champion jiu-jitsu guy of 58 no because
I sit with people and I talked on about
[ __ ] it's something that I don't have to
go look at Steve because no matter what
Steve and someone I talk about within
six minutes we're gonna be talking about
comic yeah it's true and you mean within
four minutes we're gonna be talking
about somewhere you think of this guy we
think I just [ __ ] jerk-off did you see
this [ __ ] idiots videos you know
you're always told I'm under
entertainment yeah sometimes you go to a
gym it's almost even normal people yeah
it's so true when I first started this
fitness thing I said for me I want when
I first got off coke I said I want to
get back
well was when I didn't do coke and he
should go to martial arts from what the
martial arts school so I went and
visited them and at every school people
go hey man you got a spot tonight at the
improv right away I don't care how good
the school was I didn't go back yeah
because I didn't want people telling me
about comedy so I went to the school for
a month with just black people and conga
drums doing kung-fu is black you would
do kung fu with black people now they're
the most dedicated [ __ ] kung fu
students you'll see in your life they'll
get the chopsticks out take the chicken
off the bone with either with a
chopstick they're [ __ ] savages black
people and that's what I went I went
down there was like eight black dudes
you know c400 whatever white and it
didn't I didn't talk about acting for
eight months in there
somebody said man I was watching the
spider-man 2 with my kid and I saw is
that you and then you gotta say yeah and
then I asked you what you're in I didn't
want to talk about that you know you get
sick and [ __ ] tired of talking to the
same problem people that's the [ __ ]
truth like you talk to the pizza guys
yeah everybody like when I used to work
in an office and you hang out with them
after work you go to a bar you think
you're gonna go to a bar and have a nice
drink it's always talking about my work
the boss sucks can't believe they made
us do this and it's just and then I used
to kill my stop calling out people from
work look I don't want to have the same
conversations I have at lunch so be my
man you walk back to Philly came back
with alternate [ __ ] cookies you're
looking at life is beautiful
how was Philadelphia it was wonderful we
did I opened up for run as easy at
helium that clubs great but the air
conditioners worked because July there
was [ __ ] that dudes Jewish he
hasn't fixed that air conditioning I
don't know what they talked it did it go
out when you were there it's been out
for 90 [ __ ] days that's the story
he's like a [ __ ] Jew landlord
yeah every time you get that out you're
not gonna believe it
just before you came the air we're not
the air was out last time - its
Philadelphia building is five [ __ ]
floors it's 95% humidity
yeah the alien August yeah you need the
air conditioner of a [ __ ] of a jet
plane you know so you don't
have it he's not gonna lift a rock for a
new unit right this is 55 jeez that's
why I going I'm going in November this
year oh that's perfect I went in [ __ ]
July last year and it was [ __ ]
mind-boggling
you've got to go onstage the second show
where they shirt have wet so I just
brought another shirt you know tomorrow
but it's a great city loved it it was so
much fun run as easy sold everything out
Wednesday through Saturday fit like I
don't want to like promote shows you
know what I'm saying but people they
know you're in town and it was great to
see old faces some people that like I
just worked with them like people that I
didn't even know like I hadn't seen in
20 years remember me and I'm like yeah
remember you how you do it was great I
love that I love seeing people I haven't
seen it really is weird when you see
people either a job with and now they
see you in a different light and they
come up to you actually show like what
the [ __ ] yeah that is a good time yeah
that's a good feeling and you show your
mom now my parents were down in Florida
oh that's right they imagine I saw my
nieces and nephews you saw your brother
that's all my brother yeah so my big
brother saw my little brother saw all my
aunts and uncles took a train to Jersey
because he my aunt Kathy where she's
over there in South Jersey wonderful to
go to church went to church how
different is a church and freely in the
church here there's a level of
commitment that's here it's a social
activity yeah and Philly they go there
because they really want to be that I
really believe in the next [ __ ] step
and I really believe in the next step
whatever the step may be whatever your
religion name me it's so weird when you
go to a place here any [ __ ] Church
they have here it's always some [ __ ]
a bunch of people talking about cookies
afterward and you know drinking
Starbucks coffee I thought what church
is about you know I'm saying what's up
will you play it I have about 10 minutes
left I can feel it my main [ __ ]
look at you Ted what's happening baby
boy what do you got playing for the
weekend
I'm just Paula and I'm gonna I'm gonna
try to go seven days because I'm like I
said I'm not lifting I want you to take
a rest for two days from
she motivated to go back on more I like
the elliptical I mean I haven't done
anything I'm not even sore yet I know oh
you'd be sorted
oh you can't take down a mission from
that your training partner so they Steve
Simone it's over for you
but going from here to Hollywood Park
did you bring the iPod with the flying
Jews jumping up and down you bring your
speakers look at you Maui I'm gonna even
though the head of my smoke some more
vapor pens it's [ __ ] it's Friday
[ __ ] Friday you understand me who's
better than you nobody who's [ __ ]
better than you what's going on with the
live CD what's going on with this WOC
July eleventh and twelfth I'm headlining
La Jolla
okay what about this date you got nerve
violence Irvine Sunday night well what
the [ __ ] he we're gonna promote that
yeah we got it promote that too but I'm
doing the CD they live in the salty and
their to show up with him Sunday and do
the TV again you do the next day just
keep record everything yeah that's what
I'm gonna you know what the [ __ ] is
wrong you say I got the h4n just plug it
right in that's a no and then the
producers right this guy's I these
please release six number one [ __ ]
CDs with me this is hash from the
civility now that's a hit that's a hit
this is hash I told him I like that name
from mesh that is perfect you know you
know once you're hot you gotta keep
going with those people you know he got
that energy from Gabriel with the book
was the blog you bring the blogging time
no you slip the same saying how we're
gonna document to you [ __ ] falling
down a cliff to a bad mother [ __ ]
what else you got playing you gonna
movies no I don't know I saw I saw that
Tom Cruise movie already knows okay
nothing great but know there's anything
else I don't [ __ ] know that's your
job you're the [ __ ] young man on the
show you're the one that keeps this
[ __ ] ship together yeah I'm saying
it's Friday you're the [ __ ] captain
navigate on this show I'm a fifty
[ __ ] year old man right so where you
playing this weekend well I got nothing
I'm gonna [ __ ] rest I got plans I'm
gonna man there's no
rest [ __ ] you think that a man
walk probably of here go do some
kettlebells I think that going swimming
the my life and the baby going swimming
for some [ __ ] class on Friday they're
very excited then I probably team up
with ten and the baby's gonna take a nap
then I'm gonna go write a little commie
today okay I'm gonna go write that stuff
on Ari I already got the story for Ari
story told
oh that's all I [ __ ] water what
do you got doing that one September
night and I'm probably gonna go what do
you got tonight tonight I'm driving down
to San Diego just doing the tipsy crowd
okay mal Hall look at you Evan what's a
Dipsy grown it's a bar down in the gas
light district it's a got a great little
comedy room down in the basement so it's
like one of those speakeasy cool kid
bars but mal halls been wanting to show
there for years that's what I heard
that's right and I did it years ago with
Jay Larson loved it
this is Mouse 30th birthday it's me it's
Dean Delray it's him it's gonna be great
I love San Diego I love you I might go
goodbye Bob's coffee house oh the place
tonight yeah you've been there I've
heard about it I walked all over my wife
yet they very cute what's his name is
they're making coffee the bone right for
the pastimes of rich man yeah what's his
name DOMA Robert Romanus yeah yeah good
guy good guy what in there I met him at
auditions years ago and you know what
listen there's people that you see like
if you see Brad Pitt
it's Brad Pitt yeah but less people like
Dennis Farina that you see and you go
[ __ ] Brad Pitt yes that's my yeah
absolutely you know when you see Fast
Times at Ridgemont yeah you think of
something Sean Penn you think of a big
black guy yeah yeah yeah but you also
come on
Damone stole that move Damone stole the
movie the whole movies Damone so I went
there I went to an audition three four
years ago oh my [ __ ] god this guy's
still around and I said one day they
said go to Bob's coffee shop yeah where
is that it's great the problem with it's
across the Laemmle okay so the problem
is parking
they got a pub right next to it they
in the pub have you seen that new pub
there's a little pot there and they
opened up see what they gotta do in
North Hollywood the beautification okay
I guess Obama sending a couple of gay
this is over here to fix up North
Hollywood from the federal up from
Lankershim and Magnolia up taking a
[ __ ] fix that and put money into
right there's that somewhere that's my
Laemmle correct by the federal grants Oh
from Magnolia oh that's awesome
now you know they got a sausage place
over there I've never been to like hot
dogs and sausage people rave about like
if you want bratwurst if you want a
hostage yeah every thousand Jim pepper
so everything right down the block from
[ __ ] so there's a pizza place in the
corner fire oh yeah yeah that place
always packed in and then it's [ __ ]
Lukas trap I'll tell you what the green
spaghetti the spinach spaghetti with the
[ __ ] tomato sauce ain't bad okay the
the soup the chicken soup I can ask her
all support weddings yeah I don't know
okay but the pizza you want to stab
yourself in the [ __ ] neck when it
comes it's that bad but everything else
is you know I get on a date they got
sangria yeah you're outside it's nice to
eat there oh yeah that's they don't [ __ ]
around and then swell bucks with a bowl
of soup and a couple soup it's [ __ ]
you gonna drop Haiti in that there's one
safety for those places that you leave
bingo
I just dropped 60 bucks and I had a
[ __ ] sandwich and a soup yeah it
drives me crazy [ __ ] yeah that drives me
you know so that's that place then you
walk up a little bit they have like a a
gym place where you walking right now go
over there there's a million girls and
they're the windows are fogged up oh
yeah right on the corner the guy Fabio
he's a gay man named Fabio no my god
when you do a workout with Fabio your
body just go [ __ ] yourself you [ __ ]
sappy [ __ ] that [ __ ] Fabio doing
jumping jacks suck my dick and it
steamed up they got like dropping
classes from 6:00 to 9:00 you you want
believably the glasses are fogged
and every hot broad is going in there
and you know but next to that is the
sausage plate next to that is the
Japanese joint will they jump up and
down oh yeah I read the reviews for that
place that place is crazy they give you
a two-hour window of what I'm gonna go
eat and give the way outside in line cuz
they don't know when they're gonna let
you in ah forget it and apparently it's
not even that good the sushi sushi sucks
the entertainment if you're from [ __ ]
the Midwest or something if you get high
if you go to the State Fair and have a
good time you'll have a good time in
this [ __ ] place it's Japanese people
jumping on your tables but and there's
hot chicks but nobody's showing you that
[ __ ] so who gives a [ __ ] and I'm saying
I'm gonna pay the hours to see a bunch
of [ __ ] Japanese people jump up and
down my palate for three you could get
Godzilla on Netflix
you know the [ __ ] the [ __ ] and to eat
shitty sushi but if I tell you guys some
well you know me I tell you how it is
that's the first place I went to when I
came to California it's the first place
Pavan is not that Japanese by the way I
never robbed long and I got used to
write for MADtv I drove down here from
Seattle and that's what they took me in
fact I will stayed somewhere in this
neighborhood in fact that black rider
that took me there goes to the Y I bump
into him at the Y from oh that's all huh
that's how long he's lived around here
so it's it's really amazing what do you
like working out hi I feel like it would
permit if you did not do when you get on
the up elliptical do you pay your phones
on yeah wait till you [ __ ] workout hi
take it to the next [ __ ] level you go
Joey what the [ __ ] did you do this is
from indie Simo
I guess then you'll say to me because
once you get into a storm
see what happens when you're in the
upper lip to go you look at that clock
yeah I do okay
everybody does Lee you're gonna tell me
your [ __ ] job you look at that clock
so you're looking at when you get on you
go I'm gonna do five minutes I'm weekend
the [ __ ] out of here yeah [ __ ] Joey [ __ ]
Joey's mother hey [ __ ] his daughter I
don't give a [ __ ] but coming you get the
five you start having a good time it's a
solution about it's the music that'll
take you to the next level I got a sense
the music and then a good song comes on
you go you know I'm going to ten minutes
then you sandwich 12 minutes I read the
12 let me do 15 and at 15 you're like
I'm gonna get off and then you go [ __ ]
it I'm gonna do one more minute yeah
because I'm gonna do the end of this
song and then you did 16 minutes because
the music carried you closed your eyes
don't even look at that [ __ ] timer I
hate that [ __ ] thing I see people the
smart they cover it up they cover it up
don't kow over things that why they're
doing that
yep they did and then I do I sometimes I
go to the gym just to listen to music
recruit because like my iPod is pretty
much the only place I really listen to
music that in the car I don't have a
home stereo or anything but I go alright
I'm gonna go to this all right I'm gonna
listen to Pandora on the way down there
Pandora Sinatra or loosen up cuz I walk
among all about the music
in the podcast so far in the podcast so
yeah if you're already in the zone and a
podcast is ever yeah but I think you
should put on okay when you go to that
concert to see those flying Jews and you
jump up and down it really does and
there's times that you it's something
you haven't heard know why like the
other day I like to put on bass I put on
the Aerosmith the white draw the wine I
haven't heard that in 10 [ __ ] years I
was a king queen by the 3rd song I had
the tears of my eyes
rubbing down my face and now I got to
work it out and I'm at 22 minutes and
all I was doing I'm saying like you like
I said the number would motivate you
like it motivates me like okay I'm doing
like I only have that much left I
thought that'd be no because what you're
gonna do is you're gonna surpass what
you think you can do right I don't want
you to work for that I want you to
surpass a minute and you know what
there's gonna be two days that you're
gonna do seventeen minutes and you're
gonna go I'm good with that
yeah but then a third day you gonna take
the day off and you come back and now
you're gonna pick it up to 20 and that
20 years ago I had another minute in me
yeah that's okay save it for Tuesday
yeah I'd rather you save for Tuesday in
the back of your mind you're thinking
about it let me tell you why I like
jiu-jitsu because I love going to
kickboxing with David Muay Thai America
I still drop in there from time to time
and talk to him and I'll do a private
with him the problem was I was doing it
all my life
if we're gonna improve
as human beings you have to keep
learning and you have to keep figuring
your mind that your mind has to keep
spinning eyes hmm I don't give a [ __ ] if
you're a plumber by trade that's a trade
you chose I'm happy you chose it but at
night you gotta read a book yeah at
night you got a do a puzzle you know bro
if you just gonna sit there I'm gonna
[ __ ] TV you know and learn from
Discovery I have learned how to make
meth and Ascari I learned about [ __ ]
the ice and ages you learn a lot of
history on TV but it gets to a point
that your mind has to become analytical
when I go to jujitsu and I leave jujitsu
after I come home and have my protein
shake I sit down I take two hits of the
vapor I hate the half inedible whatever
they taught me that night starts running
in my mind running in your mind okay so
I gotta push him and the hip escape and
then grab him pull a man hook my legs
cover his arms so he doesn't block the
[ __ ] base because if he does this
your flip ain't gonna work that's it
you gotta sweep us on them and flip them
over that will go over and over in your
mind you learn something that's fast
it's like a child it's like my wife says
when you play with mercy when she goes
to bed she she processes all that [ __ ]
that's so cute and then one day she'll
come on go sit you gotta stop saying
[ __ ] she's saying dick dick dick
I guess cuz you say [ __ ] okay because it
goes into a memory bank and now you do
it what do they call that when you did
you Jitsu muscle memory well yeah that's
why you keep doing it you keep doing it
ten times and then you're not even
thinking man not even thinking about it
you know that BAM that's it you got this
guy that's why I always want you to stay
analytically okay you don't have the 60
a month to join jujitsu then [ __ ]
take a [ __ ] chemistry class at the
new day whatever that's all connected
but you're always your mind is always
learning absorbing something if not if
you don't use it you're gonna lose
bro carmine Balsamo mm mine isn't they
say that to us yeah why don't you retire
carmine you have ten buildings you have
ten million dollars in the bank and he
was hutch Tobin he goes because once you
you stop using it you lose it and we're
not if we don't have time to bleed
we don't have [ __ ] time to bleed
that's why every 90 days I switch
workouts I keep doing that work night
but you got to keep switching because
your body gets a custom that's so true
in a month when you're doing an hour on
the elliptical yeah now you'd be doing
an alley you're like how I need to do is
an hour and all sudden you'll look at me
one angle dog I stopped losing weight
really yeah because it's not how long
you live tickle so you're gonna go
you're gonna find her lip elliptical you
gonna lift weights
you're gonna walk and then you're gonna
find something in a year got it
karate whether it's just basic karate go
over there with what's-his-name when's
that with Doug Benson my buddy nice kid
he's into some straight guy right he's
an ass Grant
yeah gram gram has signed up for
Japanese sword fighting
oh man you go Graham good together will
you have to whip your sword I'm Compton
I'll shoot you in the head ten times
right it doesn't matter
he's making his mind thing yeah he's
making his mind thing those Japanese did
that to do something else that was the
bridge to do something else for us to
have a successful podcast I need for you
to take your mind away from this [ __ ]
take your mind away from Paula take your
mind away from the Boston Red Sox all
that nonsense because that's all this at
the end of the day and get into yourself
and you'll see how much stronger you get
an individual and with me I hate to say
it was weed and walking I just know
could join walk let me tell you smoke a
joint walk you learned about yourself
because one minute you smoked that joint
you put your iPod on and you start over
here and Lankershim and [ __ ] Magnolia
and next thing you know you're gonna
Lancashire and victory that's 90 degrees
that's it and you gotta walk back you
gotta walk back and now you're like all
right I'm gonna put the other side of
the cassette on that's how I grow when I
was skinny since I walked around New
York City it's not because my friends
drove me everywhere yeah it's because I
put that [ __ ] so you're evolving leave
everything and eventually if you wants
to make
panic in 1973 Charles Bronson was a
hitman he used the gun yeah but she's
never kept in shot karate he was a
karate dude and he being there with
other 80 year old man huh huh because
all those little forms learning
something keeps you sharp David Patrick
Kelly warriors yeah about the play yeah
he was the reason why I'm such a good
actor I've done for the same guy and you
know people gonna tell you well John Lee
Marshall eyes don't work but that's fine
they don't have to work you not gonna be
a fighter right you're going the same
reason you went to college college
didn't do [ __ ] for you what it cost you
100 grand okay what it cost you you told
me yourself personally that when you
want the interviews they don't say to
you was your college experience like
what you go for people say the day you
go to college for four years you still
end up with no job oh yeah so what the
[ __ ] are we talking about it but I saw
that you did something with your life
well I'm your potential employer I go oh
you went to loiter London for six
[ __ ] years even though you're
[ __ ] and you got a deist ill went
every day that's really awful same thing
with Marshall watch you say to yourself
you know what I'm one day and Wednesday
Monday morning when you wake up with the
podcast machine breaks and Paula tells
you forgot [ __ ] bagels and your mom
calls you and says that she's lonely
you're a bad son
because you haven't come to visit her
and your father calls you from Florida
and says what the [ __ ] Lee you're a bad
son I'm over here dying at the end of
that you could take your car take you a
little [ __ ] karate gi take your phone
put it in your car go into karate learn
the move and the half hour into it all
that anger and all that scholarship it's
gone and you'll say [ __ ] Jodie is in
this podcast and [ __ ] my mother [ __ ]
Paula [ __ ] Terry and [ __ ] my father I'm
learning how to throw a kick I'm like I
just want it right it's so [ __ ]
interesting when I first met Steve
Simone Steve Simone used to torture me
about going to gym him and ice yeah yeah
I remember when you joined the Holi with
Jim to the boxing gym there yeah that's
why you owe you a huge to let me use the
front desk clerk yeah
no go on and I would go on at night cuz
I was embarrassed for people who see me
in the daytime we we all have the same
everywhere
it sucks cuz I'm like I was talking to
the bigger guy at the gym I was like
I've lost weight a thousand times right
if I really thought about and wrote down
how much weight I've lost it'd be like
it would kill me but the problem is like
keeping it off and like I'm just
realizing there's no like quick like you
can't lose it had some likes like a
month and it kills your life because
every one I want it to be easy like I
want by like my birthday in a month to
have lost 800 pounds but do you know my
buddy back in Philly told me that owns
the best gym it's called the irons
fortune he says he hates when people
come into the gym and they're looking
around and they're like well I don't
want to get too big he's like don't
worry about it it's not gonna happen you
know and he was like if it's easy to be
big and strong everybody would be big
and strong if it was easy to be in great
shape
everybody would choose to do it you just
put the effort in and there's that sense
of community in every gym and it leave
the guys that know the most or usually
the nicest guys yeah everyone's just I
want it because it's it's not hard but
it takes work for me to work out and eat
well so it's like I want everyone wants
it to be like if I could be done in two
weeks that'd be great
that that's why the juicing thing did I
did it and I've done everything I've
done Atkins of the Nutrisystem that's a
lifestyle everyone you fought let me
tell you something not right now Lee
within six months one day you're gonna
have to meet Paul at 8 o'clock but the
inside of you has to go to that gym and
right now it's not gonna fade right now
it's not gonna hit you but it hits me
from time to time did you get pissed off
it's like anything else in life one day
you're gonna be doing a bent-over row or
a [ __ ] high pole or you're gonna be
on your 48th minute and you're gonna go
I work this [ __ ] hard in here and now
I'm about to go home and eat the [ __ ]
cheeseburger that shit's coming to an
end yes see it all works together that's
right that's what I did yesterday your
minds will work together I just worked
out and now you're paying your bills now
you're paying for this way now you've
seen the receipt now you're saying that
when they use a Chips Ahoy on TV and in
the [ __ ] party
and the [ __ ] party when they pop and
chips are always in the [ __ ] party
this is the party now now you'll think
twice now when they listen I love wait
launches I wish that I would be one of
those guys are gonna be chia seeds and
that could be the egg whites with
spinach leaves the taste of nutmeg and
you know I love my Dolce Dolce 'z
workout
he has great spaghetti he has a great
toner recipe with the [ __ ] with the
avocado instead of mayonnaise oh he's
got a lot of great recipes but they
don't sell those at a restaurant three
days a week when I even travel right
what the exercise that was no Josh wolf
god bless his soul he said go to mind my
Fit foods they're tremendous that you
sit with a nutritionist and it's eight
to nine dollars a meal which is what you
pay for anywhere and you eat them my Fit
foods the problem with that is guys like
you and me we're going to do a New
Jersey totally I go to San Francisco you
can't even do anything I take my fifth
food on a [ __ ] plan you open my fifth
food on the plan Lee beat you to death
and Tommy your [ __ ] future terrorist
and to throw you off the [ __ ] plane
that you have Israeli thighs to the
Taliban
did your family almost think you did
they try to give you food for the plane
yeah did this but yeah what big hot but
this one I gave you didn't give you a
tuna sandwich correct no know what they
did I had homemade meatballs I had a
homemade Menna God I had that's what you
open up on a plane and people look and
go that smells tremendous we had a the
roast pork even homemade cheese steaks
it was yeah it makes you sick yeah cuz
my brother's mother-in-law straight off
the boat from Naples the best now can
you eat red meat because I thought about
this last night because I went to the
Mediterranean place I got chicken
because tonight
I have grilled mistake is red-meat okay
yeah we [ __ ] six ounces up oh you
know I'm just gonna say what saved me my
last trip home was portion control
portion control
how many ounces of meat you know I you
know I didn't overdo it like I gotta be
I used to cure your hand yeah I do a
whole PITA
oh yeah but now it's just two slices
it's the size of your hand wait watches
wait watch is very good because it's
portion control that's a county jail
diet that's what I call it's a county
jail diet so you go to you go to Denny's
and you get two eggs toast home fries
bacon and two pancakes that's a great
breakfast okay but after you leave there
will you used to look at Steve and go
I'm [ __ ] full yeah and you realize
you didn't need a left food I used to
eat to the point where I couldn't walk
to the car yep I'm not gonna lie so do
you Lea [ __ ] yeah we know that I'm
thinking about and I eat so fast Mike
not is I eat too fast meat is so I eat
three-quarters of the meal and I'm full
but then I eat it no and then you
realize wait watches makes you realize
that if you take that piece of salmon
and kind of have good and you take one
piece of bread and throw it away and you
take the cheese off that because even
catch your past calories in it [ __ ] yeah
you know sugary all that [ __ ] you could
do without you know listen I love Subway
I love the veggie and cheese from Subway
mmm my Subway sandwich is a footlong
veggie and cheese with the chips and the
soup and the cookie and ten gallons of
those sodas yeah there's nothing like
that but you know what buy a six inch
and just leave yeah yeah get a six inch
you just walk out of it and eat it and
you're gonna no I don't need it you
realize you don't need it yeah you know
when you go to Big Mac you get a Big Mac
to double fries right so some Nuggets on
the side I guess you know what house
they have the cheeseburger it's eight
points with the cheese with no
mayonnaise and no sauce on it
yep and you get a half for a fries
that's six points cuz the whole
container is 12 and a good coke and your
salary even the water in your salad so
you can always kill your cravings yes
you know you could always kill your
cravings you know what you will like you
don't need a not you yeah it's just a
little pile of Oreo cookies but I study
eating the whole sleeve you take one and
you make a deal with you so you know
what's [ __ ] up at least so far the
more thing I miss most is the diet soda
so that's show me there must be some
chemical there's a chemical thing in
there and like like that's the part
that's been killing me and I'm like that
maybe that's a reason not to go back to
it [ __ ] we on the way home we stopped at
Gelson's at rouse and get yourself today
wouldn't do everything up at nine world
caliber plays gonna cost you a couple of
yards today but don't worry about them
want to go over to this place over here
cuz even that fit protein would just be
a little protein pile in the container
okay you put the protein powder and then
you take it with you and as soon as you
finish at the gym you fill it with water
and you shake it up okay no more milk in
your milk shakes
okay that's it that cuts another
percentage at yeah
and that milkshake you know that that
milkshake is 300 calories you know you
go you buy a bunch of apples my wife's
been buying cantaloupe
you know yes that's another thing
somewhat and you've said it before and
it kind of pissed me off when I saw
people I was like oh I'm gonna have some
fruit and like don't have fretted sugar
well I think it's okay Whole Foods let
me say some buff fruit bro
eat two apples tonight number one you're
gonna [ __ ] when you start losing weight
that I cleaned that esophagus out what
you think is in your [ __ ]
wait for that too oh yeah the same thing
with me I got bubblegum in there yeah I
got [ __ ] you know granola pits you
know you got everything in your ass you
know so you gotta clean that I'm in
health and I and leave with you you're
25 you get the world by the balls it
could either fall apart for you and
eight years because the diabetes will
come in or whatever yeah it's a
lifestyle it's a lifestyle that goes of
you for a long time I want chocolate
cake every
in day I'm a STONER dog people send me
away a thousand my shut the [ __ ] up I'm
a STONER [ __ ] okay lay even
edible I [ __ ] get stoned and I get
[ __ ] hung how do you do it
because you just passed through it you
know I don't anything okay so yesterday
I went in the kitchen and I was [ __ ]
stoned to the gills there was two
peaches and there was cheese puffs I had
four cheese puffs and I had the two
peaches that's great I made a deal of
myself I could eat the half a bag of
peas bucks yeah do you follow me it's
all compromises man this is all [ __ ]
and I'm still a fat [ __ ] what are you
gonna do but I know every week I work on
it every week I get healthier you know I
drink twenty two of these things now
that's great twenty two of these things
now a day that's gotta be way better
than drinking out of sometimes there's
no more white bread in my house there
hasn't been wiped but in my house for
three [ __ ] months that's great that
helps you know I love pasta
I can eat pasta every day but now all
these people saying pasta stays at you
yeah maybe years you know what there's
nothing wrong with six ounces of pasta
right when you go to original Joe's how
much possibly give you a little mini
plate and you'll live on that and you
get full often but me and you because we
must come on yeah we need the big bowl
of [ __ ] pasta I can pastas good for
you only poor ounces yeah that's like
how they do in the middle a mint leaf or
[ __ ] Oh what's up bleep where's that
[ __ ] vapor pen well who said another
gloomy bet is that what you said Leah
give me another one set me Lou where's
the musically put a little [ __ ] rod
imma let me tell you something let me
tell you what happened yesterday
yesterday I was driving right and I went
to the edible store late night to get
Lee his goodies for the day and as I was
pulling back out and John was on mmm I
saw him by name harmony fine harmony for
me harmony by Elton John
the beautiful day will be alive wash
your [ __ ] scrub your feet paint your
toenails if you're a female you want
your feet looking good you want somebody
to suck your [ __ ] your feet gotta
look [ __ ] impeccable on a Friday
if you're a man watch those nuts put
some powder in it grab your dick sniff
that [ __ ] make yourself remember
what being a man is salute the flag do
everything today it's [ __ ] Friday was
on John blast that [ __ ] haven't seen
your face for a while oh I is still the
same spoiled child this goes beyond oh
hello
am I the only man you ever had are you
kidding me goes I mean are you [ __ ]
kidding me value harmony
are you [ __ ] kidding me
let me tell you somethin bout this
[ __ ] fruitcake he came ahead he came
out with a [ __ ] when I was growing up
this guy came out with a new song every
six weeks and not some [ __ ] song with
black people rapping on it and being
cool this guy went to a pen and pencil
when I was in the sixth seventh and
eighth grade young John did not stop he
was telling the Beatles to suck his dick
Michael Jackson either suck his dick and
suck his toes listen to us and I huh and
I'm just emotional yeah I forgot I'm
pissed off at myself for even forgetting
out John if you watch what's the movie
that came out about the guy that follows
the band he writes about almost family
there on the bus what's this mu G babe
memorize it dog when you were a kid le
Philadelphia Freda don't let the Sun go
down on me just kill me you're good
he killed it every [ __ ] six weeks and
you're sitting there so as I pull up I'm
singing this in the car got tears in my
eyes and the two transvestites are in
front of the house mowing the lawn I
swear to god this went down last night
and I opened the window and they're like
looking at me all weird and I go that's
right [ __ ] at one time Elton
John ruled the [ __ ] world and I
closed the windows and I got up and I
started singing [ __ ] out in John in
Middle Street Armani and me a really
good company and also the lady came out
to see that I was yelling about I looked
and I go that's right cuz she's an old
the [ __ ] - yeah I go nobody remembers
nothing John ruled the world she looked
at me she was drinking a beer she goes
let's have a drink till 7:30 because the
weed store closes late this one I talk
to you oh it's so creamy I goes Louise
going down tomorrow it's Black Friday
Felicia and I saw the gay guys then I
went upstairs my put some up in John on
and while I was playing out in John I
saw a Rod Stewart song the name of the
album was a blondes have more fun
hmm and I put it on and I couldn't
[ __ ] guys in the [ __ ] seventies
let's just pretend you add the storms
the WHO and Led Zeppelin they're all
fighting amongst each other yeah now you
got this [ __ ] fruitcake Elton John
dropping bombs on your mom's [ __ ]
columns you got black music old times
you got all this music Marvin Gaye and
you got Marvin get on your memory and
then you got this [ __ ] guy named Rod
Stewart who was competing with the
stones banging them out I saw this video
and I remembered how good this song was
heavily there's off the album not foot
solution fancy-free but a different one
here anything what is it know the name a
song is you insane let's nice [ __ ]
work it Utley it's Friday watch that
muffler hit that [ __ ] the
benzene ring was loose and fancy free
car my other piece on the drums the
little Chinese bass guy
the church [ __ ] is dropping on you
work smart
sounds like hip-hop oh this is early 70s
right here down Sunset Strip and in the
backseat a big black whip all around
your face what is in bad taste
baby what I think you're cute but
there's no substitute for love literally
kick this [ __ ] Lee are you
kidding me a 1 that's how we do it on
the church music dropping now nobody's
even remembers [ __ ] Bob Stewart but
I'm telling you just that you're in my
heart you're in my soul ah yeah that
dogs
I'm telling you guys you guys look at me
going Joey you're dropping this [ __ ]
black and white music on me hey listen
you can't move forward unless you listen
to this [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] be a
black belt in jujitsu if you don't know
the proper [ __ ] hip escapes and the
proper arm bars same thing when it comes
to music I'm dropping the building
blocks on you [ __ ] you smoke a
joint you sit back and you listen to
this [ __ ] and get back to me you
understand me I listen to some crazy
[ __ ] put on mary j blige without you
listen to this black [ __ ] sing
because she's from the same thing as
Biggie and all that [ __ ] when you need a
biggie rattle he's rapping knowledge on
you that's fine when you hear a [ __ ]
woman do it I was listening to this [ __ ]
all week you [ __ ] think I'm
[ __ ] around I'm trying to find the
best [ __ ] music so you guys would go
Joey while I jump out a window last
night why am i walking around a
wheelchair today after you played this
[ __ ] music for me League wow
it's it marriage implies we old it was
the flood one one white out you wanna do
another [ __ ] boo me oh thank you
you're looking that high see you're
resist I'm looking nah
that's the first [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she just
drops it on his own
like [ __ ] this pack this is black
chicks man don't [ __ ] around
little samba Tracy Morgan recovering
baby it's bad [ __ ] how come
you're not singing in this one Joey what
book have you read to you this one
listen to this [ __ ]
call the video oh [ __ ]
god damn mary j blige take that [ __ ] off
before I [ __ ] a lot eat some black
versus you brother Taylor my idol [ __ ] I
love all that [ __ ] that's musically what
made your bloody emotions that did you
listen to those [ __ ] lyrics you gotta
read the lyrics that song you'll sit
there and go what the [ __ ] was she
smoking pot with dupa I mean how [ __ ]
what you gonna give us a Donnelly I want
to take the sugar off your foot you want
a daughter look dumb I can't have one
why not you know you did good job you
did what I did a good job at the gym so
here's a [ __ ] you have old owners Dunkin
Donuts you living like a doctor it's
[ __ ] Friday Lee get the stick out of
your ass are you doing everything today
kettlebells you jumping off [ __ ]
cliffs oh [ __ ] look at the leap brought
you there you brought you a little
chocolate I can't cuz I'll eat the
entire box look at the rest of this
[ __ ] walk to Glendale back what
that was the last time you walked it
going down back never
alright the holy [ __ ] you think you're
dealing what's going on with you baby so
you have this Sunday at the Irvine
improv yep this Sunday Irvine improv hey
pit please yeah I'm taping every what
happened to the set from a couple weeks
ago I got how they sounded I never even
heard the brass and that was [ __ ]
guys I'm done judge I got a guy got yo
harem hey yeah it's [ __ ] guy god
dammit Kenny hi no I didn't say least oh
well just we want to go for more cos we
want to make sure that I don't want to
get in La Jolla but I'm gonna record
everything and if I got the recorder I'm
gonna record everything forever how
about that it just makes it easier
hi IIIi see him he [ __ ] is neat oh
that's that what probably oh so what you
hide Friday
yeah what we gon do try what we not go
at this to lose you how do the hunger
think no no I don't know bleeping your
future what there's no sleeping your
future why I'd get that kettle bell
class that sounds amazing when he finds
it so that's a game-changer you're 25
years old what sleep it's over you're
gonna show the youth of America today
you're [ __ ] it Jewish savage you know
what it means to be a Jewish savage room
now this country is forgotten you're
gonna go back to being a Jew looking at
[ __ ] holes we're gonna fire people
tripping them with suing people going
back we're going back cuz this is
[ __ ] these [ __ ] Jews are
confused the problem with these
[ __ ] these are worthless
[ __ ] Jews you're the other you're the
most powerful [ __ ] Jew out there so
police since Moses hasn't been a [ __ ]
Jew like you you know I like it
what's gonna be an Amy a new CD my
brother remember this for when you get
sad that's why I love you we did a good
podcast couple weeks ago you brought me
God the best you got me to talk about
some [ __ ] I hadn't talked about a long
time I and why I hate rich people since
I was embarrassed was a kid that was
such a great episode I can't have a good
[ __ ] time man uh you know finally the
book of rain is coming in to [ __ ]
truly a fruition
oh that's great my good friend Jessica
she's an editor she's a brilliant editor
Amina and we've been working here this
week we did a four and a half hour
session on Tuesday because with me the
best way to write is for me the outline
and just talk to her she's that good
they just hear the stories and banging
now types it out and then we talked
about it and she types it let me get
together and go over and we've got we've
got from New York City all the way the
1981 when I'm a
in high school I had to sit with her and
talk with her for four hours look at the
shape are you ready for another [ __ ]
gloomy I think you want splitting let's
split one of these little wheat
chocolate things let's do it
you can't live without you baby so we
really got into it about you know I
didn't know how [ __ ] stop I was like
you know after God took my mother
whoever take your parents life or
whatever overtakes her life like you
figure that I fell apart I didn't fall
apart
I had everything a kid kidney we figured
out the idea you know how much money I
was making when I was a junior in high
school sophomore high school I was
making $2,000 a week oh my god because I
was selling 300 UPS a week I was or 300
hit set you know different acid like
whatever they would have I would sell
whether it was Michael got a skit or
blotter acid windowpane four-way acid
whatever asset they had of these
Stroudsburg is well I sold that week and
I would I would also sell UPS I also had
a job at rental lumber and I also stole
their they got I got me the job told me
dog if I get you this job don't forget
to steal cousin up don't know I was I
wasn't stealing that I was stealing you
come along and you don't steal they're
gonna see the difference there's only
the difference thing I know I was
stealing
so you got to keep stealing I'll hook
you up with people they're gonna come to
you in those days we sold marine plywood
it was $40 a sheet but people would give
you a 10 or 20 dollars a sheet oh my god
what's marine part what's a waterproof
it's galvanized like it has some
chemical in it that won't wash it I
don't even know if the word is
galvanized don't call me stupid on
Twitter I'm just saying it's got
something so the wood doesn't rust
gosh it's got a certain chemical in or
something so I used to sell that I
people come in the back and wink at me
and they'd say give me 40 sheets of
[ __ ] plywood at $20 a piece watch 800
hours on a Friday I'm a sophomore at
[ __ ] high school it's more money than
I never now that's all please it was
this is this is some crazy [ __ ] and the
place I was working at one day this
me the mail a check you know I don't
even know if I should go here but [ __ ]
that we already started and I had this
friend that worked on the bank and he
cashed who checks for me I won't even
tell you what the amount was right and
this guy later on became like a big
[ __ ] deal with the Genovese is like
this guy though is with the Genovese
yeah in fact when I googled him that day
that's what this picture came up in
front of him in front of a judge with
the soup with an orange shirt on saying
that him and 46 other guys have been
indicted for bookmaking in Jersey Wow
and you think about it this is who I was
with when I was 16 and I got the check
not when I was sick I got to check when
I was a junior in high school because I
was a John Lennon got shot I got the
money that week that was the week I got
the money because that's Sunday when
they had the big thing from it
strawberry whatever Strawberry Hills
forever whatever the feels forever they
I went to Bleecker Bob's it was a record
store in the village oh and I bought
Ozzy Osbourne's EP which was it wasn't
even [ __ ] whatever was that diary of
a madman before that it had crazy train
Oh mr. Crowley suicide solution and
something that was all on an EP bus
number in the 80s there were eat peas
yeah EPS were [ __ ] for solace
missing-persons rat enemy Pete first rat
song was wanted man the other one that
round and I was suddenly go mmm
what was like the first time you heard
that rainbow its riff I hate listening
10w in the morning my way makes me go
[ __ ] black walk that stabbed you
that's what I'm gonna [ __ ] cocksuckin
how you feel okay look at the shape you
ready for some tell about no why not
I'm sure highly good you care bells you
never drive
you never - I live but I remembered by
talking to her like I had all this going
on you know I had no adult supervision
I went to school I got good grades and I
stole drugs but the fact was I had no
mother yeah
so I had everything a 16 year old one
but no mother yeah you know it was just
it's just been an amazing week thinking
about that because we did this on
Tuesday and for the last two days I
can't today I feel really good yesterday
in the day before I was cracked about my
life about where I was at that point in
my life at 16 that's what I was doing
yeah you're still a baby at 16 16 Miss
Martin
I did acid almost every [ __ ] day and
I'll tell you what if I wouldn't have
done that acid I would have probably
done something stupid because it'll help
me think about my next move and help me
calm down a little bit and you're so
weird to say that the Lord works in
mysterious ways showing the [ __ ] acid
made my mind work and it made me think
of all the avenues I had and when I was
talking to Jessica they had that called
one of my good friends Carlos Quintero I
was called the podcast and he has a
brother Dee Dee and I was friends with
them after my mother died I was either
at the Bender's where I slept I was a
village ed I'm the kid that's called in
Stephenville oh he had a shed behind
this house [ __ ] no heat we'd sit
there smoke dope and listen to [ __ ]
music and if I wasn't either at the shed
or Carlos Canteras house I was home so
throughout the day I would go out in the
mornings and go to school and then hook
up with my friends and you know even
three months after your mother dies
which is still very confused after you
suffer through any death I remember that
my days would be great and I wouldn't
think about my mother - after I left the
villas house or after I would leave
Carlos's house on the walk home
my mother died and I would forget and
sometimes walk to my mother's house and
wait out there and go what the [ __ ] am i
walking over for she doesn't live here
anymore
you know she doesn't live here anymore
oh my god it was just and sometimes I
would go in the house and sit in there
and wait and say maybe they buried the
wrong lady maybe my mother is gonna show
up you know people I've never talked
about the spam that I had at this time
and how bad it was and I don't know what
kept me going but it was go three guys
and after our conversation when I went
to get the needle yesterday I called the
villa and thanked him for being there
for me and I called Carlos that night
because I called him in front of Jessica
and he didn't know about this he didn't
know that he was my world that as soon
as I left his house to walk home my
world would shatter I go home and cry
myself to sleep and then get up the next
day again you know but it was weird I
remember the story indeed he robbed the
gas station like six times and it was me
and Edie like three times but then how
to recruit other people that were nice
people yeah but it was a no brainer it
was a gimme it was like a good father
type the guys name was Ernie and he was
a little [ __ ] he was cousins with
stinky Charlie and he was [ __ ] a
little [ __ ] up this guy yeah and I
used to work to Putnam for you but I got
fired for stealing everybody got fired
for stealing but stick Ernie
always kept his job Ernie wasn't all
that he had this huge wife she had a
beat Ernie was a cute little white dude
that was probably 38 that probably
weighed you know 160 pounds but her
Andy's wife was this big you knows fat
chicks that have like chocolate on their
fingers off and they just were a house
dressing they don't work they're white
trash they're like I'm oh yeah
she's just gonna get bigger and bigger
and bigger and Ernie would talk to me
about his sexual exploits or that fool
when I [ __ ] her it's so hard a [ __ ] my
god
I didn't want to hear yeah I'd be
throwing up in my mouth I didn't want to
hear this [ __ ] from Ernie talking about
how he was eating her ass and then his
my shoes Farrah Fawcett she was like the
biggest [ __ ] woman in the world and
she was a [ __ ] she was massive
so he's in town so you know he would
tell me he would tell me you know what I
like the [ __ ]
and he took [ __ ] would cocaine but I
can't afford that late night buy $7 no
no that's no problem Ernie I know how
much money do you usually have about 8
o'clock 9 o'clock yes well done I'll
come in we'll hit you in the head to
make it look okay and then we'll take
your money and at the night when you get
home
don't be an 8-ball waiting for you and
dude he was [ __ ] get home at midnight
we give him the eight ball and he'd be
so happy he's like the next day she have
candles and she was naked with a bikini
on this woman was [ __ ] huge with
pimples in the back of thighs this [ __ ]
I mean it was just a [ __ ] nightmare
and please I'm not here to judge nobody
I'm no [ __ ] Justin Bieber myself but
[ __ ] now I'm serious I'm not Justin
Bieber
the [ __ ] dog just the fact that he
would get psyched up about [ __ ] that
famous
somebody forever it was somebody forever
and she was just dead up I mean she had
not won appealing quality I will tell
you what I remember about it she had a
[ __ ] wart on her toe she was always
Beth with that's what made it even worse
than me they lived on the third floor
now there's not a third fall like the
only bad building in the neighborhood
like we had one black person I made when
they lived in that building her name was
Marla
but they lived on the third floor and he
was [ __ ] in the tub even tell me how
he'd [ __ ] all this [ __ ] so I would
just I would even tell him I was gonna
rob him I get like a friend of mine and
we attacked Putman from the back and
he'd go pump the gas and he was walking
and we'd tackle him and was punch him a
couple times he'd cover up and go now
help out we get him
of times that we just take his money and
run but we weren't [ __ ] pounding him
or bullying him we just kick him a
couple of times when the cops got there
he'd be scraped up you know and we leave
we go home me and DV were [ __ ] nuts
Karla's didn't find out about to say ten
years they saying you guys are right I
get to say you guys did what that's what
Rob Putnam fuel so we would cook them
for like 900 by an 8-ball for 250 give
it to him I take a grandma out of it
until last minute and I'd buy an eight
ball for me and Dee Dee and we would get
Batman we split 200 cash meanwhile this
poor schlub would end up on the floor
smelling like gasoline with kicks and we
give him that 8-ball book and he would
go cray the next day he's like oh I put
a Coke rock in a [ __ ] and it tastes
like a chocolate cake yeah it's probably
this probably flower has snatched in
[ __ ] Hershey's chocolate and wants
you to the coconut just became a cake
you nasty [ __ ] ha ha ha
one of the last times we got him we
[ __ ] beat him up and we took his
money
and he's like you know the cops are down
and we bought him an eight ball but we
ended up doing it I hope you get going
over there next day and he's like
where's my money because we're gonna
tell him we didn't rob like it was
somebody else he kept calling the house
I'm like what's up he had my cocaine I'm
like we thought man I got robbed last
night that wasn't us yes that was you
yes that was us so we had to go over
they explained like I went over them my
dog it wasn't us
I don't know what you're talking about
he was like you don't understand I
forget what his wife's name was it let
him Mimi he's like my Mimi had flowers
and candles burning and she had a new
bikini and then cocaine never showed up
I'll never forget him saying that to me
and me don't earn it you're past due
like I can't even Rob you no more
because you think that woman upstairs
it's some Brazilian [ __ ] model
it's [ __ ] amazing the things you want
what's up we you ready for Lily call me
back nine what were you thinking about
that hot chicken how you want to eat her
ass and [ __ ] are you sucking on that toe
with a ward on it
no just thing just robbing a gas station
five times you know Robin gasps there's
no okay he gets a walk in the park but
there's even a five shablow different
one I got nervous there's even a
funniest story this is a kid in
Florida's name was Louie cast Lido aka
digger last time I seen hey that's the
name digger last time I saw Louie he was
talking to people he's like I remember
the time he showed up in my house with a
map like a diagram and it was - he was
gonna rob a gas station cuz after a
while I needed partners I couldn't keep
robbing them by myself you didn't have
to do nothing to him you weren't gonna
get caught there was no possibility of
jail time cuz the cops never even
thought of Patna fuel and nobody gave a
[ __ ] about Freddie he got robbed every
week he was like totally out of it for
Christ's sakes
on Saturday any bigger problem right so
I was just go to like you say me man I
need money for the prom perfect when was
the last time you tackle somebody you
know like I can't attack with you you
gonna tackle something I went to his
house and I'm like Tom Doug I need your
help you need to make some money when I
do an 8-ball and you'll have some fun I
hit him with a diagram he's like it was
like a football play he had it all
diagrams it's like he did it before I
had done it before that's a study done a
couple times so he tells the story every
time he comes to my shows you say Coco
showed up on a [ __ ] diagram
you ready from who x marks the spot did
you go higher low down below behind them
or what do you do no once you tackled
them then I came out we went in his
pockets and we set him a little for a
little get him inside control and we
take his cash go stop stop I'm calling
the police and then we'd run away we
kick him in the leg or the thigh no we
run away no [ __ ] biggie what the [ __ ]
does this country forget how to have fun
this [ __ ] country has forgotten how
to have fun how to earn a dollar it just
you know sometimes they give me
sometimes you're gonna get the gas
station guy
and you go let me ask you something how
much do you make here we can't make 200
a week let me ask you so let me come
back I'll kick in the [ __ ] head cap
and let me think the money we'll split
it with chopping [ __ ] I will chop in
two ways that's hysterical I don't go
for it you sons going diplomatically you
know I'm saying I rather get kicked in
the head and get half an envelope then
get kicked in the head and get nothing
right or wrong we say yeah I don't know
what the [ __ ] talking about let me
give a shout out to some [ __ ]
beautiful people here cuz I don't know
what I'm gonna do it leave we give him a
half a gummy bear look at him he looks
like a [ __ ] Mook and eat fries
without warning my appetite for sex
makes me so horny
John Wolfe gee what is this over here
raised by wolves I Love You Jeremy katsu
death squad Connecticut and the rest of
the affiliates all over the [ __ ]
world get your [ __ ] together with takin
over Orlando Perez Joe Faria and J bish
the teacher up in Pittsburgh keep
swinging [ __ ] beside that what's
going on with you Lee I don't want to
handle [ __ ] stories about what you
believe this you believe this [ __ ]
[ __ ] let me fill this up it's time
for you to hit some papers your new
names gonna be leave APIs it's amazing
he's to rob a gas station I forgot all
about that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's why I love
when I sit with somebody cuz like I told
Jess I'll never think of this [ __ ] by
myself all right I need sorry now think
about it every day I go sure hope that
I'll come again before I robbed Putnam
fuel first of all
Ernie's probably dead that fat [ __ ]
probably said I was facing eclipses
around his mouth but he couldn't breathe
for [ __ ] days like an octopus
grabbing it was like one of those
tentacles from nock to post what so
what's with the hand up you think
Pontius Pilate said no yeah they keep
kicking them he said keep kicking it's
Friday people I'm trying to wake up the
world here and I got [ __ ] this guy
you're upset because just
I'm gonna have another donor have two
more what the [ __ ]
first off I'm gonna put this way
yesterday I want on the Rogan podcast
I thought podcasts ended we spoke about
on it for about an hour and the benefits
of it and he's right you know people
take regular supplements that's not what
I'm it's for I'm gonna honor it's for
[ __ ] optimization of your [ __ ]
life you know that's why I always take
the shrimp tank before I [ __ ] workout
that's why I take the alpha brain when
I'm writing like right now I've been off
the Alpha brand for four weeks but
Monday comes along I'm gonna go right
back on the [ __ ] alpha brain you know
all these things have helped me
tremendously we're not [ __ ] hear you
got a money-back guarantee without
forebrain you didn't get a return the
product order at the first [ __ ] time
that's how much they believe in their
product they get the hemp Wars protein
that the hemp post protein snacks they
got one of the things that has helped me
the most when I fly and that's a
turnaround [ __ ] 180 when it comes to
feeling good and it has the [ __ ]
answer for you you want to workout you
want to do the [ __ ] kettlebell you
want to do the [ __ ] ropes and all
that and it has that also I can't get
you a discount on it what I get you 20%
off is any of those supplements so do me
a favor go to Hana calm look around read
up read the testimonials they're not
[ __ ] with you
that [ __ ] five-foot-six Sicilian
doesn't look the way he does because he
sits there and he counts 20s all days he
works he knows about his vitamins he
knows about his minerals he knows about
his [ __ ] supplements do me a favor go
to Han and read up on it go to the Joey
Diaz dotnet go to the onit box and press
in Church CH you are CH get 10% 20% off
receive all the [ __ ] paperwork and
all the emails they have about upcoming
things and what they got going on
they're sponsoring my Dolce they're
doing contests with Mike Dolce on it
does not [ __ ] around I would not [ __ ]
lie to you okay even multivitamins I
live off that [ __ ] hemp Forrest
protein I live off their [ __ ] alpha
brain so get your [ __ ] together okay go
to either comm press and see you all
CH and get your [ __ ] life together
with Alec calm the same thing with
nature's bombs okay you could sit here
we're having a good time eating yum yum
donuts they sponsor the show [ __ ]
unofficially you know we got to
fat [ __ ] in a medium [ __ ] sparerib
over there so things [ __ ] go down in
their life but let me tell you something
a good healthy [ __ ] snack is naked to
box.com you pushing Joe in the Box you
get 50% off your first order get the
sesame sticks get the [ __ ] cashews
get the pepper [ __ ] pill fish cashews
get to get the chocolate-covered almonds
they will [ __ ] these snacks are
tremendous you know when you buy a bag
of chips and then you open it up and it
says they lie to you they always say
it's it's uh you know 160 calories but
then you realize there are 60 calories
of serving and you've already had two
[ __ ] servings so okay listen the
[ __ ] calories they'll have
all-natural [ __ ] vitamins in and
supplements and whatever [ __ ] you call
it
alright that's nutritionists approved
and most importantly yes they do do
business with Monsanto and that's what
you want to be no it's a [ __ ] joke
[ __ ] alright
don't in nature's box.com they have
tremendous nutritious flavorful [ __ ]
snacks i sat there with Redman there
they ate a bag of sesame [ __ ] sticks
they are tremendous go to nature's
voxcom
press in in the box and get 50% off your
first daughter but Joey how does that
work 50% off your [ __ ] first daughter
there you go that's nature's box right
there coming out of my [ __ ] [ __ ]
you understand me
cuz that's how we work in here I can't
wait to snow that fart nature's box.com
go there right now cut this [ __ ] 50% off
puppet snacks okay and they got the
black and white granola they got the
[ __ ] stuff that'll make you [ __ ]
sing like mine just did that was a
Whitney Houston solo he just did that
was a solo from I always loved you just
my [ __ ] interpretated it wrong number
three the best vapor pen in the market
my main [ __ ] gangsters over at
nailed a life.com tremendous vapors you
understand me go to nail that life
impress Joey Diaz Church Lee on the
elliptical get twenty [ __ ] percent
off that's right you heard it right
twenty [ __ ] percent off you got a
tremendous guarantee like I told Dave
and Peter last week one good thing I
always hear about mail that life
is they have executive a tremendous
customer service and in my world it's
all about customer service it's like I
he told me because I'd rather send you a
battery then you write a bad review it
cost me three dollars go to nail vet
life.com the best vape depend on the
[ __ ] market and it's back to 100% let
them know you're doing business with the
[ __ ] flavor brothers and you get 20%
off your [ __ ] oil you understand me
and then after gummies and mono so
remember I told you on it nature's box
calm and [ __ ] nailed it like did you
smell that fart no this is no that's cuz
it's [ __ ] nature's how about you
another [ __ ] goombah thought shut it I
want to put a vapor about nutrients and
stuff on it you look silly and Oh Robi
don't owe him you [ __ ] look at you you
want a candy bar no no why not wait wait
this is immigration it's not Michael
Jackson this is not Thriller
I'm loving life I'm just happy to be
here with you guys
I wouldn't even been awake would you
call it last night and I alright that's
it uncle Joey calls as well as man ah
you know Brad Williams he had a little
party over at his house
cuz he's going to Brazil for the World
Cup so he goes come over have a sandwich
have a drink if you want to drink and
then I did that and then I went out with
a nice young lady
it was a beautiful night it's my only
night I'm not doing comedy this week
yeah beautiful that's why cuz you
dedicate you don't like other people and
[ __ ] over here when I jump up and down
and do movies you should have [ __ ]
stabbed you [ __ ] from now on you
gotta have a notebook where's the app
Lee is responsible for the church or
what's happening now app every week I
want you to hit lead up and go yo
where's the [ __ ] app [ __ ] cuz I
can't hit him up enough for six months
and where's the Apple II was the
everything tells me a story the guy
didn't call him back
there's no episode two Jews every day
got a new [ __ ] story it's [ __ ] ends
tonight [ __ ]
what uh who was it who was at my man's
house Brad uh yeah probably six chicks
for every dude that that was there and I
was only there for like the first hour
two hours that midgets got a two-foot
dick dick on his [ __ ] head I'm sure
there were so many girls there he's
always got a different hot chicken
broads love midgets I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is I wish I was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] down in my knees you know why
because you could do dirty filthy things
you have to [ __ ] get on a bed with
them they could just eat your ass
[ __ ] standing up just picking up your
toes and having your nose and some
cheesy [ __ ] sucking that [ __ ]
remember leave if you want to lose
weight up to Oakland it wait a lot of
people don't notice [ __ ] juice is
better than grapefruit people either
grapefruit with coffee in the morning
Brian the enzyme it tastes them you get
that pushed you dig deep your finger
that [ __ ] and you get some of
that juice from the walls to come out
you get some of that [ __ ] cane juice
to come out of those walls that old
sperm that goes and then sits that [ __ ]
Boyd think Madonna got so thin like that
cuz she [ __ ] don't [ __ ] around
she sucks ass [ __ ] over there she goes
to England just to suck like 30 year-old
[ __ ] it's got that juice and that juice
um it keeps your skin tightly you look
like a [ __ ] young Jew
what's the matter with you look at the
shape Ian [ __ ] yeah you're all right my
brother
okay excited by your new future you know
a thin healthy young man no more [ __ ]
couches no more [ __ ] green bay no
more no English weeds who sent you -
yeah sure yeah no more [ __ ] around
with you you're taking a back old school
you're - you know you're not making
money off doing what do you give a [ __ ]
so every day before a game you want you
but this is what your new plan is for
the year when you England starts your
exercise you catch it from half-time
only that's your treat you only watch
them from halftime
if you've exercised for the first 30
minute no pregame football you ain't
Jimmy the Greek you ain't no [ __ ]
hours you only it's like you begged me
you don't give a [ __ ] you just jumping
up and down from the neighborhood who
gives a [ __ ]
you think they jumping up and down for
Uli's on down yeah what the [ __ ] it's
over we're going back the whole school
you leave dedications you're putting out
a yarmulke again we're going back to
dishonest my [ __ ] around all right
you know I know more Chipotle no more
that [ __ ] no more disgusting food no
more VIN of the book look at the pepper
that [ __ ] you ate with them [ __ ]
artificial Italians it's still you still
like that [ __ ] that shit's all coming to
an end
you're on salads and [ __ ] pencils
understand salads and pencils sell them
up your [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know
would you like to buy a pencil you know
it's like to buy a flower so I can shove
it up your ass
great that's it my brother I love you to
death I'm happy you're doing what you're
doing then do this podcast without you
so you got to be happy you know the
beautiful thing about the podcast is
every week people send us these emails
Joey you only a helping people more than
what you know really you [ __ ] Momo's
and helping us more than what you don't
because you keep me in check you know
you keep me in [ __ ] checking you know
and the same thing with Lee you make me
want to go on and do better the material
for you you make me want to come here
right what I'm gonna talk about in the
podcast and be prepared and pick good
music for you so it's not all about you
guys you guys are doing the same for me
and I want you to do the same for this
[ __ ] guy look here look at you it's
over it's over these people love you
they want your health they want the best
for you without you we can't do this
podcast so from now on I don't want to
hear that you're packing I don't wanna
hear you picking your mother up at the
airport I don't wanna hear nothing
the first thing after we [ __ ] leave
here is you're joggin you're walking
you're getting your life together you're
breathing you're gonna get a notebook
you're gonna write down your goals and
your life and what you've done every
week and that's it no more packing no
more home eating no more nothing before
you even go down there to pick up your
[ __ ] girlfriend eat that Mexican
heart food that'll kill you you gotta
run around the [ __ ]
Hollywood Park that's the only way you
could do it Lee because then in study
the four enchiladas you know you just
walked four [ __ ] laps
you just walk four [ __ ] laps ain't
even eight inch allow this I'm lead
three of them and I'm not gonna eat the
Mexican rice I'm gonna have a salad do
you follow me
yeah I still have your enchiladas
because in the Mexican rice before eight
points a [ __ ] cup during that time
the Mexican rice I don't even look at
Mexican rice no more if I got a rice and
white rice if I definitely have two I
had pork fried rice last weekend
whatever had a little cup of it nice and
I could taste the grease in it it was
delicious
I'm not gonna sit here in lies you've
been nothing better than Mexican rice
with that [ __ ] pig fat in that lard
that's why it's eight points a [ __ ] that
[ __ ] in this [ __ ] the rice at Benihana
that gives your heart that's why that
rice at Benihana is so delicious
that [ __ ] will kill you so that's all
for that's all they're gonna tell you on
Weight Watchers Lee they're gonna say to
you leave we don't give a [ __ ] if you
eat enchiladas well how many did you eat
last week eight six that means you ate
so III with a salad tell [ __ ] mama
grandma go you want me to keep [ __ ]
hanging out of here and buying cakes
everybody has a good time you got to
feed me healthiest you'll no no yeah I
mean my plan for now is aren't you have
any of it because I can't no I don't
want you walking around wounded and I
want a wee-wee when you can't have an
enchilada you're gonna walk around
wounded it's like having a chick with
you that's a [ __ ] and you can't either
[ __ ] why have her around you don't
saying right or wrong it's a hook it's
like hooking up with a chick that sucks
a million dicks a day and you don't want
her to suck your dick I need for you to
live I need for you to have a life with
that it's a Church of what's happening
now always Steve Simone what's happening
bro
well you had on me a [ __ ] story
across your neck something I'm saying
that when you drop some knowledge on me
bought doughnuts I'm here I'm hanging
out I'm listening I'm laughing doughnuts
I want you to be involved that way to
tell me a story something will happen
did you and your brother jump up on you
see The Wizard of Oz backwards tell me
something but do you remember oh I was
talking with my brother yesterday about
in the 80s when they were talking about
the backward masking and heavy-metal
songs that if when you played them
backward right they don't do it no no
nobody's talking about that every and
don't she don't want to suck the devil's
dick and already she already caught a
beatin so why go [ __ ] that about the
devil will play the music backwards or
whatever Lee it's [ __ ] Friday I can't
send these people off what's this what's
the thing that he what's that more
without Pacino and the other kid I send
you once a month wheeze oh yes I send
you out there's a passage in the Bible
what the devil's advocate yeah that was
that movie was pretty scary
that's a scary more what's the line he
says to him I send you out amongst the
Lambs that's what I'm doing with you
I send my only son out there amongst the
[ __ ] wolves dressed isn't lamb or
something like that a [ __ ] do you go to
church you don't know this passage oh I
didn't know if you're reporting look at
the sheep amongst the lambs that one
dude what is it I got a [ __ ] half a
Catholic and a half of jewy we gotta get
back to traditions in this damn when we
just open up a church for you to [ __ ]
Momo's we got ropes in there whips and
protein powders why are the ribs
I don't know Lee is an expression when
was the last time you whip somebody
never well that's my [ __ ] point once
you get a whip this we can whip Paul oh
no consider just put it against the wall
whip but that sounds terrible I can
Vives epatha you
do you have anybody uh I whip Terry last
night out the back of a belt called her
a [ __ ] Indian if I tell you what I
wouldn't be here right now
I'd be living on [ __ ] fire right now
my bed Mexico a caddy
I love you but I love you guys I love
you people at home I love that you
support the church and you support what
we're doing you know we're coming at you
straight from the heart like what's his
name in the 80s who came at you straight
from the heart
put on the king of rock by [ __ ] Run
DMC that's wearing Oh Shelly respecting
my main man Steve someone I love you
guys I want to give a shout out to on it
a shout out to nature's box.com nailed
it life calm escape pod tanked calm my
people over a [ __ ] Hulu Plus two
weeks for free I got my [ __ ]
over a dollar shave club giving you
razors and [ __ ] knives and whatever
the [ __ ] you need the rest is up to you
the rest is up to you people like I said
in the real gun podcast their day keep
showing up something little [ __ ]
happen you know I'm saying keep showing
up that's all that matters even if it's
twice a week you showed up I love you
[ __ ] have a great weekend Lee I
love you [ __ ] Steve Simone I love
you uncle Joey Sunday July at 11th and
12th la jolla combo oh yeah and then
Sunday where this Sunday at the Irvine
they give you all the fun dates don't
they yeah you got to work like a [ __ ]
savage on a Sunday people can't get to
church on Sunday accommodation so you
got a package yet tell me gonna be the
funniest [ __ ] Steve Simone oh we're
gonna see they gonna have to tell 60
minutes to suck that dick
DVR that [ __ ] talk about Jay
Leno and Chinese people riding the
horses every week they throw you with a
story like I'm supposed to give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] yeah it's mammy go see
my main man my main what's his name
Steve Simone this Sunday
you want another Hannibal before let's
do another half ago me know just to get
the price
just a little what's gone there all
right as long as you're there and my
main man Lisa at have a great
[ __ ] week in the Church of
what's happened now Constantine rain
water boxer Cleo [ __ ] the kid in
Britta the Germany the little Spanish
get in Germany El Nino I love all you
[ __ ] stay black Thank You Joey
no this show's over remember ago
naturebox calm and order great tasting
healthy snacks and 50% off snack smarter
in the new year with healthy and
delicious treats like everything bagel
chips and baked sweet potato fries
support this podcast and get half off
with your first order go to
naturebox.com/tyler code Joey that's
naturebox.com/tyler Joey and think you
didn't nail that life depend on the
market
and mentioned Jody is to get 20% off
first thing I said to myself that
[ __ ] Steve Simone zone leave this
place telling you come on you're gonna
bum hey this is a rock and roll museum
you guys don't belong in you belong but
I see
you
and when we on the take the fresh off
the bus you can hear a sound for blocks
block that is growing grow good millions
wait where's the beef
un-fuckin'-believable
man where's the Ypres
you
yours in the end
we break two needles there's three of us
but we're not the Beatles how'd you get
behind the LZ
we rock out for I'm did you see at the
door to a track and rock you're not give
it all we got to be NC we got what it
takes
let the poppers pop and the fingers
break are you [ __ ] kidding or good
are you [ __ ] kidding man
we're crossing hard times sucker and see
that they don't make no songs like these
please
are you funny